là
figaro life 19h05 nous sommes en direct
elisabeth borne est donc la nouvelle
première ministre garder cette image ça
vient de se passer il yaa les deux ou
trois minutes à peine elisabeth bornes
qui arrive à l'hôtel de matignon qui
embrasse jean castex son patron
jusqu'ici jean castex qui a démissionné
un peu plus tôt de ce poste de premier
ministre démission acceptée par emmanuel
macron et puis elisabeth borgne a donc
été nommé premier ministre première
ministre c'est bien le terme dans le
communiqué de l'elysée
bonsoir nos benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue parlementaire politologue
merci d'être là
françois-xavier bourmaud toujours
présent un grand reporter au service
politique du figaro là ça y est une
femme et première ministre c'est un
symbole armes en tout cas c'était
attendu depuis 31 ans et le président de
la république avait d'ailleurs annoncé
durant sa campagne présidentielle qu'il
souhaiterait nommer une femme
c'est un symbole oui c'était seulement
le mais si vous voulez la vie politique
c'est quand même considérablement
féminisé ces trois dernières années il
faut quand même jeu là aussi le
souligner ne serait ce qu'avec la parité
et qui permet à l'assemblée nationale
dans les exécutifs locaux et au
gouvernement d'avoir aujourd'hui des
femmes de plus en plus nombreuses dans
la vie politique mais c'est vrai que bon
pour ces cancers de matignon ça faisait
31 ans et surtout que c'est il y avait
une expérience un peu malheureuse edith
cresson est resté huit mois dans un
climat politique extrêmement difficile à
l'époque la deuxième femme premier
c'était il ya trente ans 1982 elle qui t
elle quitter
1990-92 je pars mais seulement 30 ans
c'est bien ça elle quittait matignon oui
tout à fait dans un contexte en plus
très difficile politiquement ou elle
avait eu à subir elle le rappelait
d'ailleurs encore récemment je prends
dans un entretien du du jdd et des
critiques qui selon elle est parfois
d'ailleurs à juste titre pour ce qui
pour ce qu'elle dit pour ce qu'elles ont
dit relever d'une une forme de machisme
même si cela n'explique pas la brièveté
ça ne cela ne suffit pas expliqué là
c'est la brièveté de son de son mandat
de premier ministre à matignon une femme
il pourrait plus reculées emmanuel
macron s'il pouvait alors ils auraient
pu reculer si vraiment il avait essuyé
des refus que ça n'avait pas pas embrayé
mais c'est vrai que c'était difficile
surtout après avoir dit depuis 2010 est
qui qui cherchait enfin qu'il voulait
nommer une femme à matignon classe était
vraisemblablement le le moment pas
forcément le la personnalité qui
l'aurait qui l'aurait souhaité mais en
tout cas le pas est franchi on reste
avec ses images en direct de matignon en
attendant on explique là ils sont en
train de discuter et puis tout à l'heure
ils prendront la parole c'est comme ça
que ça se passe habituellement tout à
fait parce qu'on ajoute des rebondir
juste une vraie ou la première il faut
se souvenir que lors de la démission
d'edouard philippe on avait pensé qu'il
allait nommer peut-être une femme à ce
moment là au moment où il a nommé jean
castex le nom qui circule est sur toutes
les bouches à l'époque d'ailleurs au
même encore quelques heures avant la
nomination de jean castex était le nom
de florence parly qui est ministre de la
défense et finalement le président de la
république avait fait le choix de jean
castex notamment parce qu'il cherchait
vraiment mia ce moment là un élu un élu
de terrain pour essayer de renouer une
relation peut être plus apaisée avec les
avec les élus locaux voilà cette image
en direct on attend la sortie donc de de
jean castex et d'elisabeth baume vous
réagissez évidemment sur youtube sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitch je veux
transmettre vos questions deux experts
il répond de bons elisabeth bornes
allons-y qui est-elle françois xavier
alors elle les avait deux bornes c'est
une caractéristique intéressante elle
était directrice de cabinet de ségolène
royal au ministère de l'écologie vient
de la gauche une techno techno de gauche
son parcours dans le quinquennat il est
il assez particulier ce qu'elle n'a pas
fait c'est pas beaucoup rendu visible
enfin tout cas n'a pas provoqué de
remous elle était au transport ou la
mener la réforme de la sncf qui de
réformes compliquées elle est ensuite
passée à la transition écologique
elle était la dernière au ministère du
travail l amenait beaucoup de réformes
qui étaient au programme des macros oui
alors de sas que les deux principales
réformes voilà c'est elle qui a eu aller
à les mener à d'abord la privatisation
de la sncf voilà la forme de la sncf qui
était quand même normal ça tu dois
changer le statut de la sncf qui
tiennent une réforme compliquée ce que
dès qu'on touche à la sncf mais
mécaniquement ça ça a créé des des
grèves et des photos des grèves et des
blocages
ministère de la transition écologique
l'as hautmont pour la gérer le le
ministère n'a pas laissé une trace à
croiser mais il ya quand même ce ce
tampon écologie qui colle aux au
portrait robot que dressait mais macron
de sa future première ministre il
fallait qu'elle est cette cette
sensibilité écologique et ministère du
travail effectivement
la fellation au chômage qui est une
réforme extrêmement compliqué aussi et
justement en vend parler je salue tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent claudius 15 sur
lefigaro.fr christian léon tous seins
nus dit ingénieur des ponts et chaussées
1 elisabeth borgne avait fait
polytechnique alors justement son bilan
est ce qu'elle va devoir déjà le
justifier je lis ce que me dit claude us
15 mélenchon lui a déjà souhaité la
bienvenue avait clairement on voit que
déjà il suffit de se promener sur
twitter et sur les réseaux sociaux pour
voir que notamment les opposants de la
france insoumise vous savez quoi je vous
proposerai qu'on regarde là ce tweet de
jean luc mélenchon le premier qui est
assez rigolo grande tension avoir
nomination de mon prédécesseur lui qui
se voit déjà premier ministre sera
t-elle de droite ou bien de droite
personne ne veut le job c'est un cdd de
missions d'intérim voilà pour la touche
d'humour et puis un autre tweet ou il
liste les limes les faits de elisabeth
borne depuis le depuis le début du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron regard des
baisses de la location d'un million de
chômeurs suppression des tarifs
réglementés du gaz report de dix ans de
la fin du nucléaire ouverture à la
concurrence de la sncf ratp très pour la
retraite à 65 ans en avant pour une
nouvelle saison de maltraitance sociale
voilà ce que dit jean luc mélenchon oui
alors elle incarne d'une certaine façon
si vous voulez la volonté réformiste du
président de la république et à travers
l'action qu'elle a menées en tant que
ministre si vous voulez finalement
l'empreinte de gauche qui est la sienne
c'est surtout une empreinte qui est lié
au fait qu'elle a eu un parcours
administratif sous des cabinets qui
étaient des cabinets de gorges hal a été
simple et directrice de cabinet de
ségolène royal mais l'avait été avant je
crois au cabinet de lionel jospin corps
celui ci était premier ministre elle
avait été je crois au au cabinet obsède
pas quand il était premier sous ministre
de l'éducation nationale elle avait été
également au cabinet de deux de jack
lang donc c'est en effet une
personnalité qui n'est pas
fondamentalement politique mais qui
appartient à ce que l'on appelle un peu
l'aristocratie d'état c'est à dire la
haute administration publique avec ce
parcours dont vous avez rappelé qu'elle
était polytechnicienne et ingénieur des
ponts mais de fait après quand on
regarde la façon finalement dont elle a
eu à mettre en place un certain nombre
de réformes ou de mesures sous ce
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro évidemment
ce sont des mesures qui permettent à une
partie de la gauche en tout cas la
gauche je vais dire canal historique
celle de la nouvelle halle de 2,2
de jean luc mélenchon des verts et et
l'annexion du parti socialiste la nuque
excusez moi je recherche c'est
l'acronyme en l'occurrence qui n'est pas
toujours très simple voilà qui qui pour
la nuque en effet ce sont des politiques
qui sont des politiques qui sont
considérés comme les politiques
néolibérales donc en effet ça rassure si
vous voulez le gauche de la macro ni à
l'intérieur de la macro ni mais ce n'est
pas un gage qui est donné à la gauche
qui est en dehors de la macro nous nous
positionnons je rebondis là dessus des
gages à l'ailé gauche de la macro ni
françois xavier le poste a failli lui
échapper elisabeth bornes parce que
vendredi c'était pas elle la première
dose vendredi c'était catherine vautrin
nom est sorti du chapeau et comme
toujours dans ces situations là il ya
une campagne qui s'est orchestrée tous
les opposants à la nomination de
catherine vautrin qui vient de la droite
de l air plutôt la branche sarkozyste
tout le monde est sorti du bois il ya
une une pression phénoménale sur mm
macro pour renoncer à cette nomination
alors lui c'est à dire qui et comment ça
s'est passé en coulisses expliquez moi
c'est des messages de textos fils était
inondé de inondé de messages lui
demandant de renoncer à un sommet il
peut mettre la pression de dire aux
médias
françois bayrou
françois bayrou richard ferrand
et castaner aussi christophe castaner
aussi vite et plutôt dans le camp des
partisans de d'elisabeth bornes
il ya eu stéphane ces journées toutes
les gauches de la macro nice et s'est
réveillée pour empêcher ça c'était le
père il voit là et donc elisabeth bornes
qui finalement est nommé premières
minutes je rappelle que nous sommes en
direct il est 19 heures 14 elizabeth
borne est arrivé il y a une dizaine de
minutes à matignon elle a embrassé jean
castex ils sont entrés à l'intérieur de
l'hôtel de matignon pour s'entretenir et
puis ils vont sortir dans un instant
pour s'exprimer dans ce genre de
passation j'ai l'impression qu'on se
souvient presque
delà du discours de la prise de parole
de celui qui s'en va c'est toujours
assez émouvant c'est presque plus
émouvant qui a qu'à l'elysée on se
souvient qu edouard philippe avait été
acclamé par les gens qui travaillent
avec lui oui sans doute parce que celui
qui s'en va et plus libre et donc elle
ne parle plus libérés puisque lé les
plus tenus par la fonction donc j'ai
toujours une
petit message qui ce qui se glisse dans
le propos du partant en revanche celui
qui arrive mais tout commence en fait
les les ennuis commencent il faut
surtout pas faire un pas de un pas de
travers en débutant donc c'est
l'arrivant le nouveau nommé fait un
discours qui est plutôt convenue celui
qui est sur le départ il ya parfois une
forme de soulagement qui sait qu'ils
s'expriment parfois une forme de deux
dépit de quitter matignon mais ça reste
quand même tout le temps dans un cadre
républicain on va reparler d'elisabeth
bord mais aller un mot sur sur jean
castex quand même quel bilan que
retiendra-t-on de jean castex arnaud
alors c'est un peu paradoxal parce que
jean castex a été finalement assez
critiqué durant sa période à matignon
mais finalement comme tous les partants
ils bénéficient aujourd'hui de son lot
de regret de son lourd d'indulgence
janquin sexe a été surtout qu'est ce
qu'on retiendra de jean castex pas tant
son bilan législatif que finalement
l'homme de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire est en tout cas de toute la
seconde partie de la crise sanitaire
avec ses confinement sert confinement la
question des vaccins la façon dont il
faut négocier avec les collectivités
locales
la mise en place de la politique
vaccinale par exemple tous et tous et
tous ces sujets qui ont
vraisemblablement
disons créer une empreinte au tour de
jean castex jean castex il avait été en
fait recruté pour deux raisons parce que
il était d'abord un excellent
connaisseur de l'appareil d'état du fait
lui aussi de son parcours dans
différents cabinets ministériels en tant
que secrétaire général adjoint de
nicolas sarkozy il avait été aussi
recruté parce que c'était un élu local
d'une petite commune prades dans les
pyrénées orientales donc ça permettait à
emmanuel macron dont on disait qu'il
manquait déracinement local d'abord un
premier ministre qui parle à ses
territoires voilà cette france et puis
cette france périphérique que cette
france des territoires cette france du
tyrolien terroir et après le gilet jaune
c'était arrivé après le gilet jaune donc
si vous voulez tout cela était disons là
aussi dans la feuille de route de 2,2 de
jean castex il a plutôt rempli a assez
on peut le dire correctement cette fille
nommée laverie là le vrai problème qu'il
faut le faire la vraie question qu'il
faut se poser aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir qu'est ce que c'est qu'un premier
ministre aujourd'hui
avec le quinquennat qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un premier ministre sous emmanuel
macron finalement est ce que cette
fonction n'a pas perdu un peu de sa
substance politique lorsque l'on a connu
d'autres premiers ministres dans
d'autres périodes qui eux étaient des
poids lourds politiques qui étaient les
véritables dirigeants de la majorité et
qui parfois d'ailleurs pouvez même
s'opposer à leur président de la
république c'était le cas de jacques
chirac avait réalisé que service a été
le cas de michel rocard également avec
françois mitterrand tout se passe
aujourd'hui comme si finalement la
fonction de premier ministre n'était
plus tout à fait la même que celle
qu'elle avait été il y a maintenant de
nombreuses années on va en parler ça
explique peut-être aussi le temps pris
pour trouver un premier mise peut-être
que ce poste de premier ce ne fait plus
autant envie est ce qui est une forme de
continuité françois-xavier entre jean
castex elizabeth banks je lis mafalda
qui nous demande sur lefigaro.fr quel va
être son programme et autres questions
en substance combien de temps pour
constituer le gouvernement discute
d'abord le programme va aller dans la
continuité de celui de jean castex et
dans la méthode ce qu'il y aura aussi de
la continuité alors le programme c'est
celui des mails macron bas forcé à celui
qui a été présenté pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2000 22 cas pas
forcément passer le mur du çon parce que
la campagne a été particulière mais
plutôt le programme d'e mails macron
depuis 2010 est qui consiste à essayer
de réformer la france le
de la redresser en fait en dix ans en
fait
elizabeth banks et jean castex au
féminin c'est exactement le profil que
recherchait même macron c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui connaît l'appareil d'état
qui arriva s'orientant fakih qui
maîtrise le ce qu'on appelle les techno
1 c'est ça mais c'est le terme qu'on va
voir fleurir partout dans la presse
demain pour qualifier pour qualifier
elizabeth banks et la techno de gauche
voilà c'est il ya une techno de gauche
succède à un techno de droite après la
question pour elisabeth bande ça va être
de réussir à
peu imposer son style jean castex a mis
du temps à
trouver son rythme il avait été nommé en
remplacement d'edouard philippe la
mission de jean castex au départ c'était
de préparer la relance de la france
d'après covin et il s'est retrouvé
replonger dans le dans le comique avec
les nouvelle vague de l'épidémie
il est sorti de cette épidémie de kovy
dit pas si longtemps que ça en réalité
même pendant le canton commence la
campagne présidentielle en septembre on
est encore sous reste donc le jeu jean
castex qui étaient là pour incarner la
relance de la france a finalement est
finalement passé à côté de sa mission
mais bon il a fait le plan de relance
mes
livres il avait d'autres chats à
fouetter si j'ose dire vous apprenez de
toute la place dans l'actualité et
malgré ça il a réussi à imposer un style
celui de quelqu'un de plutôt empathique
sympathique qui ne nourrissait pas
d'ambition donc il n'a pas arrivée à
l'elysée quand il est entré à matignon
me après ils font ce que c'est surtout
sa quatrième modèle macron de son procès
ce que cet équilibre qui a réussi à
trouver jean castex pas d'ambitions qui
ne fait pas de vague mais qui en même
temps le protège parce qu'on dit souvent
que c'est le rôle du premier ministre
est-ce que elisabeth bornes va réussir à
entrer dans ce rôle là est-ce qu'elle a
les caractéristiques pour arnaud a
écouté il ya un qui différence avec
quand même même avec elisabeth board
pour jean castex et quelques gens cassés
que c'était un élu s'était fait élire
dans la commune de prades donc il avait
l'habitude de l ancrage territorial puis
traiter la matière humaine quand vous
êtes année nous oui quand vous êtes un
élu et surtout un élu dans une petite
commune vous traitez la matière humaine
j'allais dire presque au quotidien et
donc ça on voyait bien que jean castex
il savait faire même s'il était parfois
un peu moqué et puis il avait cette
action du sud-ouest qui arrondissait les
angles sur le plan de la de la
communication et isabelle borne non ils
avaient deux bornes elle a un parcours
encore une fois de haut fonctionnaire
qui a fait du cabinet ministériel est là
il préfète si elle était préfète qui a
été président de la ratp annonce grandes
entreprises publiques qui a été ensuite
donc ministre mais qui disent on
n'appartient pas ce qu'on appelle le
cursus honorum e républicain c'est à
dire je me fais dire et puis ensuite je
gravis les échelons c'est à dire la pole
alors que j'enchaînais les parties à 20
euros un peu comme emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière aussi
bon donc ça c'est une maintenant elle
est ciblée il va falloir que le défi
pour pour elizabeth banks est un peu
j'allais dire ou pas trop cette
expression parce qu'elle est employée
aujourd'hui à tous bouchons mais a fait
une faille dans l'armure c'est à dire
qu'il va falloir qu'elle incarne une
campagne électorale on est quand même
dans une campagne législative donc le
premier ministre en principe c'est le
chef de la majorité c'est lui qui doit
mener le combat politique pour
célébrités on était donc c est les dix
ans dans une aile et elle rentre dans
une arène qui est un peu nouvelle pour
elle on va voir comment elle prend la
fonction et comment elle prend son rôle
françois-xavier bourmaud d'accord doit
mener la campagne des législatives c'est
vrai ce que nous dit arnaud
théoriquement c'est oui oui
théoriquement les petites nuances sur le
sur la question ce qu'en réalité le chef
de la majorité c'est emmanuel macron et
on voit bien qui s'est dotée avec jean
castex mu puis elisabeth bornes une
sorte de super directeur de cabinet qui
va qui va gérer l'état la machinerie
tout le volet technique de l'état pour
lui la campagne des élections
législatives
les français vont pas voter pour
elisabeth bornes c'est pas elle qui va
se retrouver sur les sur les affiches
elle va peut-être sans doute faire des
déplacements de terrain courts pour les
soutenir des candidats mais la tonalité
l'orientation de la campagne ça va être
emmanuel macron il a déjà commencé
d'ailleurs en s'en prenant à demi-mot à
jean-luc agent libre à demi-mot nomme
même franchement à jean luc mélenchon
placer au rang des non-sens sa volonté
son discours sur l'europe notamment sa
vente ait pas de sortir de les traiter
mais sans la franchir enfin le combat
des législatives il est déjà engagée
entre entre mails macro et jean luc
mélenchon des jeunes occasion de revenir
sur le tweet de jean-luc on peut le
revoir c'est vous les remettez à juger
un tunnel qui est en régie de nous le
roman sur le commentaire de jean luc
mélenchon sur elizabeth banks et un
commentaire de campagne c'est sessegnon
c'est un commentaire de campagne
électorale parce que peut être gêné aux
entournures avec elisabeth bornes on l'a
dit elisabeth bonne elle vient de la
gauche est elle peut parler à cette
frange sociale démocrate qui du ps qui
se reconnaît pas forcément dans une
alliance avec la nouvelle france
insoumise la nuit la nuque selon marc
réussir à le dire oui mais klein est
allé seul même jean luc mélenchon est
avancé par le maire et donc si c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle ça aurait
été plus facile pour jean luc mélenchon
de combattre une catherine vautrin qui
vient de la droite une sarkozyste et de
dénoncer le l'ancrage à droite du
président comme de nuit cinq ans là il
ya quand même quelque chose qui est qui
qui se joue aussi
nationale et zabeth bornes en vue des
élections législatives nous sommes en
direct 19h23 depuis vous l'avez vu la
cour de l'hôtel de matignon ou elisabeth
borne est arrivé il ya une vingtaine de
minutes elle a pris chaleureusement dans
ses bras jean castex ou inversement
peut-être ils sont entrés à l'intérieur
et puis ils doivent en sortir d'une
minute à l'autre maintenant vous voyez
cette image tout à l'heure ils doivent
en sortir pour prendre la parole 19h24
donc je le disais ça lui didier van
d'helle qui nous dit elle à 61 ans oui
c'est vrai on n'a pas précisé la 61 ans
elisabeth voudrais qu'on parle de de son
caractère de son charisme ça fait cinq
ans qu'ils aient le gouvernement c'est
l'une des seules un qui est resté aussi
longtemps qui a fait tout le quinquennat
elle n'est pas forcément très connus
c'est une timide on a l'impression que
c'est une timide quel est son caractère
j'ai plutôt une bosseuse c'est pas une
personnalité très extravertie
c'est une personnalité discrète qui
finalement a pratiqué son ministère
comme un directeur d'administration
centrale pratique son administration
centrale c'est à dire que sans volonté
réelle de s'exploser autre que celle
finalement de s'exposer quand on lui
demandait de s'exposer pour deux pour
défendre tel ou tel point de son de la
politique de son département ministériel
donc ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui va
j'allais dire naturellement quand
d'autres politiques face caméra mais là
il est évident que maintenant à partir
du moment où elle devient on remarque
que c'était le cas aussi de jean castex
d'une certaine manière et qui a appris à
progressivement domestiques et les sa
relation avec les médias là en effet bon
maintenant combien elle est en train
elle endosse le costume de 1er mai de
premier ministre puisque je crois que
c'est exact et un logis consacré d'après
le communiqué de presse oui lequel a été
réveillé et qui fait froid de l'elysée
il va falloir que évidemment elle rentre
dans ce dans cette danse est unique la
et qu' elle soit j'allais dire plus
proactive dans sa communication
politique notamment à la fois vis-à-vis
des parlementaires des troubles
politiques de la majorité
des oppositions et vis-à-vis des médias
donc pour elle c'est un changement d'une
certaine manière de seine changement
darren et c'est là qu'on va finalement
juger si elle est en mesure de sa
culture et à ce que constitue
véritablement le jeu politique est
parfois le jeu politique dans toute sa
violence aussi françois-xavier vous
suivez pour le service politique du
figaro la majorité comment l ai vu
comment elle et vous l'avez déjà
interviewé ce que vous pouvez me dire
d'un point de vue personnel sur
elisabeth bornes il n'y a pas
grand-chose qui déborde c'est toujours
des propos très très carrée pas de pas
de pas de petites phrases ou de de datta
khel un politique il ya totalement oui
ça va voyons c'est énorme alors il
faisait attendre alors il ya une
peut-être une pression effectivement
elle a pas eu l'occasion que s'exposer
parce que les dossiers qu'elle a géré
les réformes qu'elle agirait donc le
réforme de la sncf et assurance chômage
donc qu'ils étaient des réformes très
politique en réalité étaient portés par
les premiers ministres en exercice
j'irai le volet technique enfin elle
était en back-office voilà pour le fond
peut le dire comment elles n'étaient pas
exposées politiquement à l'assemblée
nationale ou uniquement pour répondre
sur des questions techniques de la
sculpture icm ans étaient ces ministères
qui devait porter ses réformes mais
finalement elle n'était pas mise en
avant c'était plutôt le premier ministre
ou d'autres personnalités du
gouvernement oui parce que c'était des
sites et des réformes politiques dont
qui était qui était portée par edouard
philippe jean castex ou et qui est au
pot pour le coup elle n'a jamais eu à
affronter s'est retrouvé dans
l'hémicycle sous nos yeux comme tous les
ministres ou les mercredis aux questions
gouvernement mais pas en première ligne
voilà en back-office jeu j'ai lu que
lorsqu'elle était patronne de la ratp
elle est appelé burn out parce que la
tendance a vraiment tiré sur ses équipes
alors demandé de beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé presque trois semaines
d'attentes arnaud tout ça pour ça j'ai
envie de vous dire elisabeth borne est
le premier nom qu'on a entendu à la fin
de la campagne et on en arrive aisément
oui
d'un côté déceptif pour prendre le voka
alors ma chronique force est de
constater que c'était un nom qui était
cité dès le soir de la victoire
d'emmanuel macron donc c'est un nom qui
est d'une certaine manière sans surprise
quand on regarde dans son ensemble la
séquence mais c'est vrai quand on
regarde la séquence de ces dernières
semaines et surtout de ces derniers
jours il s'agit d'une surprise puisque
ça a été très justement rappeler c'est
que le nom qui avait été quand même
identifier ces 48 dernières heures ce
n'était pas le nom d'elisabeth baume
mais c'était quand même celui de
catherine vautrin très clairement
vendredi les choses ont pensé que les
choses étaient faites il s'est passé
quelque chose durant le week end ça
signifie quelque chose quand même
c'était
géré ce retournement de situation
signifie que emmanuel macron qui
pensaient peut-être que sa réélection
lui permettait d'être mettre totalement
totalement de la situation politique et
du contexte politique à l'intérieur de
sa majorité ne l'a pas été totalement
puisqu'il y a eu un certain nombre de
barons de la ma chronique qui sont
montés au créneau pour s'opposer à cette
nomination et qui considérait que cette
nomination n'était pas la bonne
nomination pour justement permettre de
gagner les élections légistatives et
harnes je vous coupe parce que vous
voyez sortir de l'hôtel de matignon jean
castex elisabeth bande évidemment on les
écoute
normalement c'est jean castex qui prend
la parole en premier maintenant on va
les écouter les applaudissements des
équipes de matignon pour le premier
ministre sortant et celles qui le
remplace
[Applaudissements]
merci madame
madame la première ministre cheikh
elizabeth
mes chers concitoyens mesdames et
messieurs je suis cher elisabeth
particulièrement heureux de t'accueillir
ici à l'hôtel matignon siège
la chefferie du gouvernement dans un
moment toujours solennel et je tiens à
le dire d'emblée particulièrement
émouvant pour moi
je voudrais d'emblée si tu me le permet
exprimer toute ma gratitude et ma
reconnaissance
après c'est moi qui depuis
juillet 2020 m'ont conduit à la tête du
gouvernement de la république à faire
face avec le peuple français à une série
d'événements tout à fait exceptionnelle
difficile douloureux
et je voudrais d'abord exprimé
évidemment ma reconnaissance au
président de la république de m'avoir
fait l'honneur et donner la possibilité
d'exercer cette
très haute fonction
et j'allais dire tout simplement de
servir mon pays
je voudrais dire aussi au peuple de
france
combien je sais que les mois écoulé
marqué par une crise sanitaire
inédites ont été
difficiles
combien cela engendrait de décès de
souffrance
combien nous avons dû prendre
sous l'autorité du chef de l'état des
mesures difficiles mais je veux ici
saluer
résilience
de nos concitoyens
la solidarité
qu'ils ont exprimée au delà de
contestation qui se sont fait jour mais
dans l'ensemble
nous avons ensemble fait face
j'ai essayé
avec le gouvernement avec l'ensemble des
services publics de mener le bateau dans
ces circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles avec je le redis un seul
objectif
protéger
apaisé
expliqué
rassembler fédérer
ses remerciements je les dois aussi
évidemment
à l'équipe gouvernementale
dont tu faisais cher elisabeth parti et
au delà de cette équipe
à mon cabinet bien sûr au service
exceptionnel qui tu le verras travail
ici à matignon mais tu les connais des
gens pour l'essentiel et au delà à
l'ensemble des agents et fonctionnaires
de l'état et du service public
pour ceux qui en doutaient
ça n'a jamais été mon cas la france a
montré
qu'elle disposait d'un état et d'agents
du service public formidable bien sûr
bien sûr
comment ne pas évoquer d'abord celles et
ceux qui concourent à notre service
public de santé publics et privés
d'ailleurs qui depuis le premier jour on
fait face avec un courage et une
abnégation absolument exceptionnel à
toutes les vagues d'à pandémie combien
de fois me suis-je rendus à leurs côtés
dans les services de réanimation
d'urgence dans les hôpitaux dans les
établissements de santé dans les centres
de vaccination je veux leur redire en
votre nom la gratitude infinie de la
nation pour ce qui s'est passé
nous avons mon gouvernement a tenté à la
demande du chef de l'état d'en tirer
déjà ça c'est appeler le ségur toutes
les premières conséquences pour remettre
à niveau ce service public dans la
pandémie a rappelé une nouvelle fois le
caractère absolument indispensable et je
sais cher elisabeth que tu aura à coeur
de poursuivre cette action ma
reconnaissance s'exprime également aux
membres du parlement et notamment à la
majorité parlementaire qui m'a toujours
été fidèle d'une grande loyauté qui a
pris ses responsabilités
et je crois dans le plus grand respect
et de l'état de droit et des
prérogatives de la représentation
nationale
la crise sanitaire vous le savez n'a pas
été le seul événement auquel nous avons
dû faire face plus près de nous
évidemment
la guerre aux portes de l'europe à nuque
rennes qui n'a pas fini de faire peser
toutes ses conséquences y compris ici
dans notre pays et je sais que c'est une
des priorités que tu auras coeur de
traiter
mais
je veux avoir une pensée particulière en
ce moment aussi pour les victimes les
attentats
des attentats terroristes qui ont
meurtri notre pays
alors que je me trouvais ici à l'hôtel
matignon
je pense bien sûr
à samuel pâtit
l'attentât de conflans sainte honorine
mais je pense aussi à stéphanie
m'enfermer
et l'attentât
terrible dans ce commissariat
je pense aussi aux victimes aux trois
victimes à notre dame des anges à nice
je pense aussi à ce policier assassiné
en avignon tout cela marque beaucoup la
nation
et renforce notre détermination
et je sais combien tu l'as partage
à lutter sans relâche contre le
séparatisme et le terrorisme
je me suis donné sans retenue à cette
belle et haute fonction en veillant
toujours à ce que je crois
fondamental
à ces valeurs que nos concitoyens
attendent eux par dessus tout au delà
des décisions qu'il nous faut prendre
l'engagement la sincérité
le bon sens et la proximité
la société souffrent certains de nos
concitoyens
rencontrent des difficultés
à le peuple français est un peuple
exigeant je le sais il ne prend rien
pour argent comptant
il le soupèse tout
mais il sait faire face c'est un grand
peuple un peuple politique
la fonction share elisabeth n'est pas
davantage
exemple d'exposition et de critiques
andy même elle a été créée pour ça
et là ce cher elizabeth je crains qu'une
de ses critiques tu sois épargné celles
relatives à ton accent personne n'est
parfait
n'oublie pas quoi qu'il en soit
que en réalité
il y à ce qu'on entend beaucoup
qui s'expriment fort et oh
et puis il y à ses millions et ses
millions de nos concitoyens
que l'on n'entend jamais ou si peu et
qui sont là qui observe qu'ils agissent
qui mènent leur vie
faites comme les autres deux heures et
de malheur il faut veiller à ne jamais
les oublier
il ne s'épanche pas forcément sur les
réseaux sociaux
il n'occupe pas forcément les chaînes
d'information continue mais ils sont là
et ils sont la colonne vertébrale de la
france
cette france qui est confronté tu le
sais à d'immenses défis
la crise sanitaire n'est pas tout à fait
terminée
la crise en ukraine et toutes ses
conséquences sont là la question du
pouvoir d'achat sur laquelle je le pense
mon gouvernement a déjà beaucoup agi va
occuper pour renforcer et amplifier et
dispositifs que nous avons pris loin de
toute mesure de démagogie et de facilité
qui aurait pour conséquence que
d'affaiblir durablement notre économie
et d'appauvrir davantage encore à
l'arrivée les plus vulnérables d'entre
nous
j'ai confiance chez elisabeth d'abord
permets moi de te le dire en toi tard je
te connais je te vois agir tu étais au
gouvernement avant que je n'en devienne
le chef mais depuis juillet 2020 j'ai pu
je veux le dire à la nation
observé t immenses qualités de droiture
d'intégrité de compétences de
volontarisme
temps aptitude certaine à relever les
grands défis que le président la
république a soumis au peuple français à
l'occasion de l'échéance majeure qu'est
l'élection présidentielle la transition
écologique
l'égalité des territoires
l'aspiration à la justice et à l'égalité
toutes ces valeurs
que tu as ancré en toi même et depuis
longtemps surtout j'ai confiance dans le
peuple de france
dans les grands talents que celui ci
recèle pour qu ensemble
de façon solidaire déterminé par notre
travail par nos efforts partagés nous
puissions fasse faire face à ces grands
défis je serai autant que tu le
souhaites à tes côtés ma chère elisabeth
comme je les dis est annoncé je ferai en
ce qui me concerne un pas de côté en
sortant de la vie politique nationale
dans laquelle je me suis finalement
rentré qu'un peu par effraction en
juillet 2020
je continuerai bien sûr à servir notre
pays il ya tellement de façons de servir
son pays quand on les aime en dehors de
la politique
à toi même au gouvernement de la
république et à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens à notre pays à l'europe
aussi je souhaite de tout coeur
bonne chance
je souhaite le meilleur car je n'en
doute pas nous en sommes capables je
vous remercie
donc apte ex applaudi dans la cour de
l'hôtel de matignon qui donne la parole
à isabelle borne je sors de la politique
nationale qui suis entré un peu par
effraction il a exprimé sa fierté salué
les français en faisant allusion à la
crise du colis c'est vrai que son
passage à matignon restera probablement
marqué par cette pandémie on écoute les
applaudissements et puis le premier
discours d'elisabeth bornes en tant que
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh jean
merci tout d'abord pour ton engagement
sans faille au service de notre pays au
service des françaises et des français
tout au long de ces derniers mois
merci aussi pour tes mots et puis merci
pour les nombreux combats que nous avons
menés ensemble précisément au service
des français
alors je suis sûr que beaucoup de
françaises et de français ont comme moi
un pincement au coeur au moment où tu
t'apprêtes à quitter ses fonctions
parce que tu as su conquérir le coeur
des français en sillonnant sans relâche
notre pays en allant à leur rencontre
tu le sais je crois que tu as
certainement battu tous les records sur
le nombre de déplacements d'un premier
ministre mais ça nous a permis de
découvrir ou de la de tte grande qualité
d'écouté et d'apprécier des qualités
humaines
toute la sincérité et toute la capacité
je veux dire d'empathie vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens
alors tu l'as tu l'a rappelé quand tu as
pris ses fonctions il ya bientôt deux
ans
les défi était immense d'abord la crise
sanitaire était toujours là dans notre
pays et on nous annonce et une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent
grâce à ta détermination à ton
engagement je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
peut le dire les résultats sont là nous
avons pu protéger des entreprises le
taux de chômage est au plus bas depuis
15 ans nous avons agi pour le pouvoir
d'achat même si tu l'as dit il nous
faudra continuer à agir tout au long des
prochains mois
moi je voudrais dire à quel point j'ai
apprécié de travailler à tes côtés
pendant ses 22 mois alors nous avons
évidemment des différences mais je pense
que nous avons aussi beaucoup de choses
en commun
d'abord nous partageons la conviction
que les politiques publiques doivent se
bâtir dans le dialogue le dialogue avec
les élus avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les associations avec lesquelles
nous avons travaillé sans relâche tous
ces derniers mois et puis même si nous
venons de familles politiques
différentes
je pense que nous sommes également
attachés à l'intérêt général à la
cohésion de notre pays à l'égalité des
chances il s'agit pu le mesurer
notamment dans les projets que nous
avons porté ensemble pour la jeunesse
alors vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
poursuivre dans cette voie face aux
nombreux défis que tu a rappelé qu'ils
sont devant nous je pense notamment à la
situation internationale mais aussi aux
défis climatiques et écologiques sur
lequel il faut agir plus vite et plus
fort et je suis convaincu que nous
pourrons le faire en associant encore
davantage les forces vives de nos
territoires parce que c'est bien au plus
près des français qu'on trouvera les
bonnes réponses et c'est bien tout le
sens aussi de la nouvelle méthode voulue
par le président de la république
alors comme vous l'imaginez jeu je suis
évidemment très ému ce soir et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour la première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves et rien ne doit
freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société
monsieur le premier ministre cheikh gens
je pense sincèrement que vous êtes une
personne rare parce que vous privilégiez
toujours le collectif et que vous
incarnez ce qu'est un ministre ce qu'est
un premier ministre c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un qui sert son pays donc merci
très sincèrement libre à vous
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour ce premier discours
d'elisabeth bornes la nouvelle première
ministre alors que jean castex à lui les
équipes de matignon je vous propose
qu'on écoute c'est toujours des moments
assez émouvant des moments intéressants
aussi de voir comment était perçue le
1er août
[Musique]
à 24 ans quittent l'hôtel de matignon on
va rester sur ces images on va continuer
d'écouter d'entendre ses
applaudissements avant de parler de ce
que vient de dire elisabeth bornes force
habitués la nouvelle première ministre
ces images là c'est comme ça à l'elysée
un contre évidence en vain alors quand
il sort quand il s'en va c'est son
mandat est terminé et il a perdu 6 il a
perdu ses bons effectivement se sont pas
du tout ces scènes là et quand son
mandat est terminé de mémoire le dernier
est parti sur cette représenter ces deux
êtres jacques chirac
mais je ne me souviens plus de façon il
y avait mes faits et nicolas sarkozy
arrive nicolas sarkozy a redit mais
françois hollande c'était parfait oui
oui
ces images arnaud benedetti qui montre
la proximité
une des qualités qu'on nous foute
souvent séché jean castex oui c'est un
nombre de contacts c'est un nombre de
proximité vous avez raison de le dire et
là dessus il est pas trop et il est pas
trop hauts fonctionnaires justement
parce que il a encore une fois cette
expérience
qui les d'élu local qui fait que lila
j'avais dit une empathie qui est assez
naturel qui n'est pas j'allais dire sur
jouer en l'occurrence mais si vous
laissez des scènes assez je vais dire
traditionnel départ des premiers
ministres de matignon en sorte qu'on est
évidemment il y à un clash c'est arrivé
notamment en 1976 quand vrai que c'est
vrai que claquent la porte de matignon
avec valéry giscard d'estaing mais ce
sont des scènes que l'on retrouve
j'allais dire de manière régulière dans
les départs des premiers ni c'est à dire
il salue en effet les gens qui ont
travaillé avec lui il ses collaborateurs
c'est vrai que quand on se remémore
l'arrivée de jean castex et quand on
écoute ce discours premier peut-être
constat que l'on peut faire c'est que il
est beaucoup plus à l'aise aujourd'hui
en partant qu'il ne l'était en arrivant
et on peut le comprendre parce que
évidemment le poids des responsabilités
est considérable pour tout nouveau
premier ministre et il a quand même moi
c'est ce qui m'a frappé dans son
discours insisté sur cette expérience
qui a été la gestion de la crise
sanitaire oui en rappelant qu'il avait
été obligé de prendre des mesures
difficiles qui ne plaisait pas forcément
à tout le monde et que y'a pas sur
lequel ils incitent toujours qui
décident beaucoup sur lequel il incite
beaucoup ces derniers temps sur 6 nov
finalement qu'est ce que c'est que la
politique c'est servir et il l'a redit
là il avait redit jeudi dernier
lorsqu'il a fait ce ce dîner avec
l'ensemble des des ministres c'est chez
lui je crois quelque chose qui est très
important et sur lequel en effet il
reviendra à jean castex qui semblent
s'en aller à pied de l'hôtel de matignon
tient comme un certain valéry giscard
d'estaing en quittant en quittant
l'elysée
il a dit françois xavier se sort de la
politique nationale j'y suis entré un
peu pas effraction c'est intéressant ça
oui c'est là qu'est ce que ça fait
directement référence à l'élection d'
emmanuel macron qui est qui est lui-même
disait être entré à l'elysée par
effraction il ya deux
sur élections lui sur nomination les
deux mots
signal en tout cas que c'était pour mm
macro un trailer inattendu et pour jean
castex un premier ministre inattendu
effectivement c'est une personne issue
de la droite après un premier ministre
déjà deux de droite étaient pas
forcément la nomination qui était
attendu en juillet 2020 ça s'est étendu
avec avec edouard philippe et sa
plaidait déjà au sein de la macro ni
pour plutôt un virage vers la gauche
voilà pour les dernières images de jean
castex probablement avant un moment il
nous l'a dit je me retire de la vie
politique nationale et on débrief quand
même ce qu'a dit elisabeth bornes qu'est
ce que vous en retenez arnaud les
premiers mots les premiers signaux
écologie féminisme le dialogue lundi qu'
elle était là pour incarner la nouvelle
méthode du président de la république
donc on voit bien que elle veut d'une
certaine manière signifier qu'elle sera
une première ministre à l'ecoute à la
fois des partenaires sociaux et des élus
locaux elle a insisté sur ces deux
points voulons dire que finalement d'une
certaine manière les réformes qu'elle
mènerait et qu'elle serait amenée à une
roma menait seront menées en
concertation avec les corps
intermédiaires
elle a parlé de la cohésion aussi donc
vous voyez là vous avez deux sujets de
thématiques qui peuvent parler d'un cas
en partie à la gauche il ya eu bien
évidemment la référence à l'écologie est
elle a terminé sur une touche un peu
personnel rappelant que l été la
première femme nommée depuis trente ans
à ce poste avec un hommage à
dit christine cresson est un message
volontariste à l'adresse des jeunes
femmes qui finalement souhaite plus qu'à
s'engager dans cette arrière quelle
qu'elle soit je démens cette nomination
à toutes les petites filles je les
encourage à aller au bout de leur rêve
arnaud
une petite question quand même qu'est ce
qu'elle va pouvoir faire dans l'est dans
les semaines à venir parce que notamment
sur la réforme des retraites on sait que
c'est l'une des principales mesures
proposées par emmanuel macron elle n'est
pas forcément d'accord avec ça elle ah
oui alors maintenant que la première de
la compétition qui va être la sienne la
dans les heures qui viennent la nuit
déjà commencé cette forme et oui les
deux former un gouvernement jeudi son
gouvernement qui soit un gouvernement de
combat la vraie question est ce que ça
sera un gouvernement resserré où est ce
que ce sera un gouvernement plus large
quelques les tonalités aussi j'allais
bien en termes de couleur politique sera
donnée à ce gouvernement est ce que le
curseur sera plutôt vers la gauche ou
plutôt vers la droite bon autant de
questions qui vont alimenter la
chronique politique des chefs de ces
prochaines heures françois-xavier votre
première réaction après le premier mot
d'elisabeth bornes je dirais que le
mystère se renforce et si vous avez
comme ça
le regarde on ne comprend pas toujours
pas ce qu'est cette nouvelle méthode
défendue par paris mais les maquereaux
et dont on a parlé lisabeth banque
l'avait mettre en oeuvre la nouvelle
méthode sur les territoires au plus
proche des citoyens
c'est le le paquet cadeau on sait pas ce
qu'il ya dedans voilà et on attend
toujours de savoir ce que c'est que
cette nouvelle méthode pour la faire la
transition écologique mettre en place
les réformes n'a toujours pas de de
réponse sur la façon dont mails macron
entend passer de macron un hamac rond 2
c'est à dire faire totalement différent
de ce qu'il fait dans son premier
quinquennat doit le le mystère
s'épaissit on voit bien dans quel cas
quelle direction va mais on sait pas où
on va c'est ce qu'on voit sur la forme
les français vont devoir s'habituer à sa
parole sa voix sa manière
de parler de répondre aux journalistes
qu'est ce qu'elle montre là déjà dans ce
premier discours sa manière dont elle va
pouvoir appréhender son poste là c'est
ce dont on parle est au tout début de
l'émission avant le avant la passation
de pouvoir le premier ministre qui
quitte matignon et comme il est il est
déchargé d'une tâche d'une lourde d'une
lourde de tâche il ya toujours une forme
de main peu de soulagement ou en tout
cas le poids du pouvoir saleh je
disparais en tout cas pour celui qui
arrive tout commence et ça devient salée
les ennuis commencent et pas des petits
ennuis et justement je lis et je le dec
sur youtube qui me dit avec le
changement de l'âge de retraite elle va
pas traîner longtemps par la population
tout de suite là on a fait face aux
mesures et on prend de plein fouet la
vision de la population sur soi doit
elle entre la langue dans le mur et va
commencer par la réforme des retraites
fans c'est son gros dossiers soixantaine
pas le premier mais en tout cas c'est le
gros dossier de l'année le poids des
responsabilités commence à peser sur ses
épaules et n'a pas le droit de faire un
mot de travers d'où un discours à peu à
peu compassé en tout cas nettement moins
libéré que celui de jean castex jeu j'en
viens à la fin de cela il est évidemment
on va se projeter sur sur les quelques
jours qui arrivent arnaud il faut faire
un gouvernement
comment ça se passe comment ça va se
passer
d'habitude est ce qu'il ya des tracts
tractations est ce que certains sont
déjà sûrs d'avoir leur poste ou et bien
non il faut encore négocié négocie tour
est très incertain à ce stade là aussi
on sait très bien que le poids du
président de la république sera
essentiel dans la constitution de ce
gouvernement il l'a toujours été mais il
est peut-être encore plus avec emmanuel
macron bon là la difficulté c'est que
c'est un gouvernement qui est construit
pour aller jusqu'aux élections
législatives c'est à dire que c'est un
gouvernement qui doit à la fois être un
gouvernement qui montre qu'il rentre de
plain pied dans l'exercice des
responsabilités qui sont les siennes
qu'il va mettre les mains dans le
cambouis pour un certain nombre de
problèmes pendant trois semaines en là
on a un gouvernement qui est toute façon
un gouvernement de transition forcément
en l'occurrence un c'est toujours le
c'est toujours le cas lors de ces lors
de ses lancers succession autre élection
présidentielle des élections
législatives il ya toujours des
correctifs d'ailleurs qui sont apportées
lors du ce à dire que lors de l'anglo
serré et apprenait alors on peut
imaginer en mai secrétaire d'e on peut
imaginer mais tout ça tout ça ce sont
des hypothèses on peut imaginer que peut
être dans un premier temps les manuels
mouscron va vouloir que l'on constitue
un gouvernement resserré un gouvernement
de combat et un gouvernement qui soit
prêt justement à affronter l'élection
d'initiative parce que ce gouvernement
il faut pour qu'il puisse perdurer que
le président de la république obtiennent
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale au
mois de juin c'est quand même une
condition sinequanone et qui n'est pas
quand même une messe une mince affaire
forcément donc ça c'est un premier point
ensuite bon il ya après les dosages
encore une fois les dosages entre les
équilibres à l'intérieur de la majorité
des équilibres entre la droite et la
gauche de la macro ni les équilibres
entre les différentes formations qui
composent la majorité on sait que
emmanuel macron aime aller chercher des
profils qui ne sont pas automatiquement
des profils d'élus des profils de
politique il avait notamment constitué
quand même des gouvernements avec
beaucoup d'experts venant du monde de
l'entreprise soit de la société civile
soit de la haute fonction publique est
ce qu'il va là aussi disons continuer
dans cette voie ou est-ce qu'il va
rééquilibrer
vers des profils plus politique son
gouvernement qu'elle est aussi pour
important les qu'ils allaient dire
l'équilibré territorial c'est très
important vous savez quand on constitue
des gouvernements alain juppé a rappelé
récemment je le regardais dans un
documentaire ou lançant le gouvernement
de 95 qui devait être un gouvernement
resserré est devenu un des gouvernements
les plus importants de la vème
république parce qu il avait fallu à un
moment donné trouver les secrétaires
d'état ou des ministres issus de telle
ou telle région donc tous et toutes ces
variables avec toutes ces variables
rentrer dans la constitution bien
évidemment de d'un gouvernement dernière
question françois xavier en termes de
calendrier à quoi peut-on s'attendre là
dans l'est dans les jours à venir le
gouvernement ils tombent quand quand
est-ce que je connais et quand est ce
que nos internautes connaissent le
ministre des affaires étrangères lui ni
de l'économie etc etc alors si c'est si
c'est un gouvernement effectivement
resserré pour aller jusqu'aux
législatives
disons que ça peut prendre moins de
temps que d'habitude voilà ça peut qu'à
48 heures peut-être mais ca ca rubik's
cube en fait un gouvernement a constitué
si vous bougez une phase youn et une
autre qui se défait donc faut essayer de
faire tenir tout ça là quand ça dans
l'ordre moi vous avez de caries sur le
biscuit c'est facile à faire donc si
c'est un gouvernement resserre oui ça
peut ça peut aller vite avec disons deux
contraintes importantes celle de réussir
à faire incarner l'idée de changement et
la deuxième c'est de maintenir des des
ministres d'expérience donc de concilier
le changement et la continuité ça va
être compliqué de la première chose et
deuxième chose c'est de mettre en place
un gouvernement qui soit immédiatement
compréhensible par les feux par les
français sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat qui va être la question centrale
au coeur de législatives or cette
question là elle est gérée normalement
par bercy donc on va revenir vers
l'histoire du changement et de la
continuité
vous mettez un ministre d'expérience qui
connaît ces questions là bruno le maire
donc qui a fait ses preuves dans le
quinquennat précédent pour régler la
question du pouvoir d'achat ou en tout
cas élaborer des mesures ou alors vous
pariez sur le changement et vous mettez
quelqu'un d'autre au quick et c'est tout
est vraiment question d'arbitrage
complexe et tous et ministrable qui vont
passer par le prisme de la haute
autorité de la transparence et de la vie
publique ça aussi ça peut freiner la
composition de ce gouvernement
elisabeth borne donc qui est devenue
aujourd'hui la 25e premier ministre de
l'histoire de la vème république la
deuxième femme trente ans après edith
cresson une femme c'est un symbole fort
envoyé par emmanuel macron merci
beaucoup monsieur d'avoir été avec moi
on se retrouve vite sur sur figuerola
évidemment puisque on suivra la
composition de ce gouvernement dans les
jours à venir merci à julien qu'une aile
qui a managé tout ça en régie pour
pouvoir vous offrir cette passation de
pouvoir et puis essayer tout au long de
la journée de connaître le nom
d'elisabeth bornes qui est enfin sorti
c'était tout à l'heure aux alentours de
18 heures merci excellente soirée à vous
sur figaro l'aïe